all right ariel
yes sir ariel oh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally i grew up
in new orleans louisiana
tell me about your family
i grew up in foster care got molested by
my
dad um
then
ran away met this pimp
at the age of 13. something like that
and
sorry if i cried it's okay
you wouldn't be the first
wait
and he said he was protect me from the
white man
i remember when i first started
he was like i ain't gonna let nobody
rape you or whatever and he was like
just sell some [ __ ] or whatever like
i didn't know what i was getting into
but my first date was with
this older white guy
it was like a hundred dollars
and from there on
i just felt like that was my protection
he wasn't gonna let nobody rape me no
more
or you know what i mean foster care
going through that this is louisiana
and then i went to vegas
i stayed there i was like 15. stay there
when my first pimp
is yp you know pimping or whatever
i stayed with him for like since i was
13 and 15
and then went
all around the world i'm talking about
it's my first time being in los angeles
but i've been to
probably 40 states prostituting
since i was like
13. how many how many pimps have you had
like
eight
um
most of them like they sell us a dream
like
you know like it's not like
like we think we're
making it
like ends me our rent really we're just
selling ourselves just to
make them cars and houses and stuff
it's not what we
and then
we end up like this
abused
what happened to your face um i um he
was
he like threw a beer bottle
and it shattered
and then my collarbone
it shattered
i got 10 fractures in my
back
for my x-film
um
yeah
it's been a rough life
is this something that you wanted to do
as a young girl at 13 you probably no
how'd you get into it
um
mommy wasn't there
you know
foster care
got molested by the foster father had a
kid by the foster father they took the
baby away and i met the pimp and he was
supposed to be my shining armor
and that didn't turn out that way
i don't want to go home
this is so much us girls out here that
i'm i'm lucky i'm not on drugs
um
i pop ecstasy pretty much that's a drug
but you know what i mean there's girls
out here that smoke crack there's girls
i have to do methamphetamine i'm not one
that does that
and so
but
last night
showed me like you know
this ain't your life area
i saw
it could have been me got shot last
night on fig
dude got shot and
it like scared me you know what i mean
and i met this girl last night on the
blade and it was like
this ain't for you you know what i mean
and um
i don't know just last night showed me a
lot like
i need to go home
or i need to go to like
i heard this place called children of
the night
it's like for prostitutes and stuff like
that
you're on the streets i ain't gonna lie
i've been thinking about it
at the artist
i've been thinking about it but what
you're doing
no disrespects are i don't know if i'm
legalized to do this
what you're doing makes us girls have
hope
i think you know sharing this
information is probably
i think it's helpful for everybody i'm
just saying you know
no disrespect
know me on camera or whatever but
when people like you don't care on the
outside between me and god
people need hope
that there is better ways you know i
mean that
you
how you letting us do our testimony
that's what's up bro
you don't stop doing what you're doing
because sometimes if you don't just save
one of us even if i go back out there
you're gonna say what
and that's what's the key
you know what it means i see what you're
doing
so
yeah
sorry
how old are you i'm 30 you're 30. do you
have children
i have three i gave my children um to my
sister-in-law she's an evangelist
because i didn't want them to live the
lifestyle i'm living
you couldn't have quit your lifestyle
and raise your kids yeah
but
at the time
i chose
lifestyle over my kids
i'm an honest person like you know what
i mean
[Music]
were drugs a part of the picture then no
never been
just ecstasy yeah i had a bad pretty
much that's
but like
most of us girls
so i don't know about them but
some of us girls we're not addicted to
the drug we could put the truck down so
quick
we're addicted to the life
to the love of the streets to the
mommy and daddy didn't give us attention
so well we go you know what i mean it's
a mind thing
but
this pimp dude he gonna hide your back
you know what i mean he's gonna be like
daddy that's what we call him
he's gonna be like our daddy pretty much
do you think you're looking for love and
that's with the streets or yeah that's
what we get offer
it's like it's like a poison that
ventilates in us
and sometimes we can't get up like you
know i like
sometimes there's no way out
like right now during my testimony
this is a chance to go like god's
showing me
will i go i don't know because
i'm so used to that lifestyle
that i don't know
but this right here
what you doing
i want to do that
just to think about it what if a girl
actually
got what what you're doing
is in the game that actually been in the
game
and actually be successful and do what
you do
we'll save so much people like i think
also girls that are considering doing it
might hear these stories and right take
their lives in a different direction
right
like if you can have a girl on your team
to do the right thing
to save us girls that actually got like
say for instance um
i stopped prostituting and go get my
life together go to the church another
night and come back
after this day you never know you know
yeah that's happened it's happened
before right and we're like bro actually
what i did
[Music]
and another girl actually work with
children
you know
do what you do yeah i think a few girls
on the street had options that were
clearly like oh that's another option
for me but i think you get addicted to
fast money right you guys yep
and not even just fast money either it's
just like
um
we get addicted to like the life like on
pimps chasing us up and down the road
like
no disrespect but it gets exciting you
know it's like a it's like a car show
you ever seen a car show like people are
like going racing and [ __ ] like that
we're addicted to going out there and
running around
it's psychotic really but
if that's all we know you know i mean i
think the the way you're treated by men
and pimps and tricks and all the
everybody on the street it matches your
low
self-worth yep
you know um actually that you probably
have god is good let me show you
something right quick
this lady gave me this
and it's called created for a purpose
and um this morning i read it every
morning to give me strength before i go
outside
and he's and it's called talking about
my self-esteem that
my body is a temple
i learned that today that our body isn't
simple and um what we put in our body
not just what we put in it but how we
treat our body
is according how god allows us to live
you know prosper and um this morning
i asked god i said god
i was this much close i put then on the
right hand of the bible of getting shot
last night
because i just got off a date
on figure
who was shooting who um some mexican
guys it was a rival
it had nothing to do with us you know
what i mean it's just the wrong price at
the wrong time the gangs are thick down
there
the gangs are thick down in that
neighborhood it's not even just that
like some of these girls like
um for instance i saw this girl she was
telling me the other day like she was
scared
um to leave
because she's
she's not just with a pimp she's like
like a gang member
and so like a lot of the pimps down
there are gang members no no
okay pimps aren't game bangers they're
not allowed to gang bang
but they only got
hustler pimps that's or max you want to
call it these [ __ ] are from
like the turf and if you leave them
they'll try to kill you and [ __ ] it's
just crazy as people
it's a rough situation it is
and only a girl with low self-worth is
going to be attracted to that yep
situation because once you find out that
you can get hurt
once you find out
before okay for instance
god puts us through so much
to where
like right now
i don't even
seeing the interview of you
trying to save us
makes me want to go to children of the
night
[Music]
go back to your ex film
he gonna do you right
it's just [ __ ]
you just never know you know
but me personally
talking to you bro
it actually
[Laughter]
but tonight's another story
you're gonna need that money for a room
you're gonna need the money yep
and he said you know what
um i just left my film
yesterday
i made a thousand dollars last night
and he didn't
he left me out there you know what i
mean and like
wouldn't answer the phone
so i had to go back outside
to get some more money so i can get me a
hotel
and that's just tiring i ain't gonna lie
like
looking at me right now
you'll be like dumb she's on drugs
but
it's not you're gonna go test me
it's the
the tiresome like i wear myself out worn
out
one o'clock in the afternoon [ __ ] i've
been uh since like five since yesterday
honestly
so you're after this you'll probably go
to a room and get go give me a room
do you have to report you have to you no
no more i just left my ex you left your
pimp so you're free yeah right now i'm
free
could you go back to louisiana or
anywhere to uh that's what i've been
thinking about honestly um
but i want to go to like one of the if
if i get out the game i got to go to one
of them children of the night programs
because i know my my strength i've been
in the game for so long when i get rough
i always lean back i can take you right
there as soon as you're done here
you know what i mean yeah so
it
takes the inner power
like i said even if i go back outside
if nothing changes nothing changes if i
don't want to change what i'm doing
i'm not yeah you won't stick with it
right
but we got soldiers like you gonna pray
for me
i think the majority of girls that go to
the places like that
i think i'm sure they would tell you
that a lot of the girls will run back to
their pimps yeah
it's it matches your low self your self
image self worth right and that's what
fits for that
mindset you have but if if you can
feel better you know if you can believe
the angel on your other shoulder that is
telling you you deserve better
then you can thank you
you're like one of our angels yes i'm
trying to do but if i
if i harp about how you need to do this
you need to do that no one will watch
the videos no one will do anything
but i i know one thing
today
is the day like maybe maybe like
we need like soldiers like you no
disrespect is how we talk but soldiers
like you
around like to let us know that
everybody
not not one
thought process
would think that i'd be here telling you
our testimony
i think we all deserve something better
than what we're giving ourselves
but that's not that's easily said
it's hard to change your subconscious
view of yourself yeah but that's really
what needs to change
yes sir
hey all i need is this
for you it's good for you to talk
because you certainly can't have these
talks on the street no not even with my
wifey's
you know what that is right
you're the girls with the pimp
not even with them like
you got to keep all this [ __ ] inside
all right ariel thank you so much for
sharing your story god bless you god
bless you keep it up
we'll check in with you in a few weeks
and see if you went to the children
you